Melissa and I have a major goal for by
the time I'm 40
so we'll fill you in with what that is
soon Kim Kardashian teasing her latest
her project
[Music]
yes the 39 year old mama Ford took to
her IG stories over the weekend
revealing her ambitious Saturday night
plans okay we're doing a night workout
before my dinner which I never do with
this one but I figured we have to get
into it at some point but here's the
real reason for Kim's pre-dinner sweat
sesh this is one of my falling off times
where I am I think 18 pounds up from my
from what I was about a year ago a year
and a half ago the reality stars weight
gain isn't from not working out the
workout begin in fact she's practically
the queen of posting her fitness routine
on social media
it's my eating I workout I love junk
food and I love fast food I love sweets
ice cream Kim was back in the gym Sunday
morning captioning this video of her on
the Stairmaster quote a morning workout
after a night workout is the best I feel
lazy if I'm not working out and I just
don't feel good about myself you'll
remember in August 2018 Kim concerned
fans after revealing that she'd gotten
down to 116 pounds if she ultimately
apologized for a number of comments she
made when celebrating her weight loss
and here's what she told et last month
when asked about her current priorities
I'm really good focused on like beauty
fragrance skims law school mom she's not
necessarily in that order but that is
more than enough for me
[Music]